mon abri ce qui est avec nous brice
merci brice d'être là bravo mombris
chaque année les bras déjà témoin héros
d'avoir gagné l'épreuve des poteaux moi
je te le dis franchement ça fait plaisir
c'est que c'est une belle victoire je
suis content et merci du coup de
l'invitation ça fait graver plaisir m et
brice je te dis l'épreuve des poteaux
pour moi on rentre quand même dans la
légende de koh lanta quand on gagne
l'épreuve des poteaux et prix à partir
de demain ou que tu as tu vas la
boulangerie tu vas la boucherie du nid
donnez-moi de merguez
j'ai gagné les bons débuts
[ __ ]
mombris balle la star de photos on va
dire mais c'est vrai que c'est
franchement c'est que du bonheur de fête
destinaire comme ça en apothéose sur les
poteaux au bout de 2h40 et c'est dingue
vu mon parcours en plus est
on plie dernier rouget
mais offre
en tout
poulet suis hyper fier de cette victoire
mais brice moi ce que j'aime chez toi je
trouve que tu as un garçon extrêmement
sympathique qui c'est vrai il s'est aidé
de sportivité incroyable et c'est vrai
que c'est ce qu'on disait alors le
casting cette année vous êtes on a tous
envie de vous kiffez en fait il n'ya pas
de mec quoi des tests non mais c'est ça
non mais c'est vrai je suis d'accord
c'est vrai qu'il ya eu quelques
stratèges dans l'aventuré
moi j'ai dû le devenir alors qu'au début
au départ je n'étais pas du tout c'est
vrai qu'on ce qui est ressorti sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est que les trois
finalistes étaient vraiment trois
personnes que les gens aimaient bien
donc c'est un positif pour certains
c'est un négatifs pour d'autres qui
aiment un peu la plus la stratégie
voilà c'est vrai qu'il ya des saisons
plus stratège que d'autres celle là
était peut-être un petit peu moins
c'était voilà peut-être plus le sport la
compétition qui comptait moi j'ai adoré
cette saison franchement j'ai trouvé
qu'il ya eu des rebondissements
j'ai dû un peu jouer des coudes et le
plaisir de tout repos la tête de tout le
monde mais écoutez la semaine dernière
tu es bon moi je vois là vous savez je
kiffe koh lanta voilà et en plus je le
dis voilà c'est la même même boîte de
production que nous voilà cc voilà c'est
cdc c'est une boîte de production
cousine bon alors en plus donc mais je
peux mais je peux dire du mal de koh
lanta c'est vrai que cette année moi je
trouvais qu'il y avait pas de grosses
personnalités comme ya pu avoir et de
grands champions comme claude mais tu
vois parions tôt à brice
voilà donc qui fait parce que tu es
quand même été quand même un grand
sportif
est ce que quand on a entendu pascal
dire que à cause des réseaux sociaux
vous pouvez peut-être lever un petit peu
le pied avoir peur de ce que vous faites
est ce que toi ça tu as traversé
l'esprit pendant l' aventure ou pas du
tout à ce que vous pensez à ce que vous
dire les gens alors je pense qu'il ya
des candidats qui ont réfléchi
évidemment à ce qu'ils allaient dire ils
ont posé chaque mot ça je pense que
vraiment il y en a comme comme a dit
pascal qui pensaient peut-être à la
suite par rapport aux followers twitter
etc
c'est vrai que ça peut sembler assez
vite mois pour le coup j'ai assumé tous
mes choix là à la fin de l'aventuré
notamment le choix de d'alexandra était
pas facile je les assume et j'ai fait un
choix stratégique
loïc était l'ultime l'ultime favori tout
le monde voulait clos il gagne voilà
j'ai assumé mes choix jusqu'au bout peu
importe le mal que j'aurais pu faire
voilà j'ai dit moi c'est je choisis
alexandra pour avoir plus de chances de
gagner
ça n'a pas fait malheureusement mais
voilà j'ai assumé mes choix jusqu'au
bout et ça j'en suis fier tu penses que
tu aurais mérité de gagner parce que tu
as remporté l'épreuve des poteaux ou pas
parce que celui qui remporte l'épreuve
des poteaux mines en aura peut-être des
gens c'est le gagnant de koh lanta
alors c'est ce que les gens de chez moi
évidemment me disent que j'ai gagné les
poteaux et je suis gagnant de koh lanta
je n'oublie pas que oui
gagnez des poteaux mais non je suis
malheureusement que deuxième de koh
lanta
alexandra a super bien mené sa barque
elle a hyper bien gérée elle a fait
sûrement plus d'alliés que moi dans la
voiture et elle mérite amplement sa
victoire vraiment eu brice je voudrais
qu'on voit une image de toi quand tu a
fondu en larmes après avoir découvert
ton apparence regarder cette image ça
c'était vraiment c'est une image forte
de cette saison regarde on peut
emprisonner
well as et ouais
je suis à 53 kg et je réalise pas
là où je me rendais pas compte 53 élus
je fais presque ri de 81,8 à lui c'est
nous brice alors est bombe restée
toujours beau et inquiète pas là non
plus il perd gros s'ils n'ont plus battu
voilà mombris tu reste quand même très
bas mais c'est vrai si tu veux venir
manger à la maison avec ma mère on
prendre encore quelques kilos tubes et
aqua tube brice je vais me faire passer
un petit tour d'accord tu veux mon chéri
tu vas voir je peux d'ailleurs dumas
mars que ces transformations
là tu vas vraiment plus réellement
chlorés mombris je dire tu attends tu
attendent l'heureux événement ouais
c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
tu vas être tout jeune papa eva écoute
on ne souhaite vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de bonheur et brice si
tu passes dans la région dans le
quartier tu viens nous voir quand tu
veux tu es ici chez toi et moi tu
ailleurs je ne sais pas si tu sais mais
tu sais que j'ai travaillé dans le
public de touche pas à mon poste à
l'époque et je m'occupais si si je
m'occupais des personnes dans le public
et c'est donc la vérité ça qui n'a
franchement je vous jure franchement
j'ai toujours bien déconner on a
toujours bien qu'il fait même si les
primes il était fan finie c'est vraiment
voilà c'était bien série c'est bien ça
briche
eh ben tu viens nous voir mais vraiment
je charrie pas c'est pas un mot en l'air
tu viens nous voir vraiment quand tu
veux mais vraiment trop monde sur paris
avec plaisir je viens vraiment c'est
hebri je te fais des normes bisous et
bravo qu'un grand galop millions bravo
bravo bravo
[Applaudissements]